on va en parler davantage de cette
histoire de netflix qui a perdu 35 pour
ça aujourd'hui de sa valeur qui perd des
clients c'est un champion toutes
catégories qui galopait depuis des
années catalina briceno au professeur à
l'école des médias de l'université du
québec à montréal est avec nous madame
boissonneault bonsoir bonsoir bon alors
il ya une conjoncture bien sûr il ya la
guerre en ukraine il ya des clients
disparu en eux en russie apprécié que
n'empêche qu'est ce qui explique selon
vous il ya d'autres facteurs que leur
lumière jaune qui s'allument là pour
netflix
oui en fait il ya plusieurs facteurs qui
expliquent la situation dans laquelle
netflix se trouve actuellement
je vous dirais qu'une réponse 1 il
pleuvoir simple ici que tout ce qui
monte doit redescendre un moment donné
c'est quand même dix ans de croissance
continue avec notamment des années
d'acquisition de nouveaux abonnés tout à
fait record pour netflix on pense à 2020
première année de pandémie donc ou
netflix avait gagné 36 millions de
nouveaux abonnés puis 18 points 6
millions l'année dernière alors c'est
pour ça que je dis un peu à la blague
tout ce qui monte doit redescendre mais
la vérité c'est que il ya plusieurs
facteurs effectivement qui rentrent en
ligne de compte
certains de ces facteurs là était
prévisible certains d'autres sont plus
circonstancielle mais une chose qui est
certaine et le constat pour moi le plus
important qu'on peut tirer à l'heure
actuelle c'est que c'est de réaliser à
quel point la performance boursière des
entreprises qui qui joue dans ce marché
du streaming et notamment une entreprise
comme netflix est presque exclusivement
basé sur sa capacité à gagner et à
retenir des nouveaux abonnés et ça déjà
ça nous indique un problème au niveau du
modèle d'affaires et du modèle de
revenus mais si on revient aux facteurs
en tant que tel qui explique
effectivement cette cette chute cette
situation dans laquelle se trouve notre
fixe actuellement il y avait des
facteurs qui était prévisible qui relève
de l'évolution en fait des marches g et
de l'offre pour ce type de service là
d'abonnement streaming on les a nommés
évidemment le fait évidemment que la
concurrence depuis le 10 mai 2018 s'est
énormément accrue on a juste à penser
ici au canada en la prolifération une
multiplication de l'offre de vidéo sur
demande donc par abonnement avec non
seulement des joueurs canadiens mais
également plusieurs nouveaux joueurs
américains et force est d'admettre que
les gens évidemment face à toute cette
offre low se sont lancés dans de
multiples abonnement mais qu'on arrive à
un moment où peut-être tout le mondre
dessin petit peu sur terre surtout à
l'aube d'une crise économique et d'une
inflation galopante où les ménages
doivent faire le choix moment donné de
dire ben je ne peux pas payer pour tout
ça bon justement à deux choses
intéressante j'ai reprendre vous êtes un
peu trop c'est comme pas assez laid il
ya trop d'offres allait créer des
compagnies en afrique c'est loin d'être
seul il ya des joies qui se sont imposés
aussi et mon nom est ce que tous ces
joueurs là peuvent vivre en même temps
tout le temps
bien sûr que non forcément il va y avoir
un tri site c'est un processus tout à
fait normal dans lorsque se développent
des nouveaux marchés un ya des périodes
de très forte croissance et après ça il
ya des périodes d'écrémage puis à des
périodes où est-ce que effectivement les
gagnants le remporte soit par
consolidation les joueurs s'achètent
entre eux pour devenir de plus grosses
entreprises ou à un moment donné il ya
des pères il ya des joueurs qui perdent
des plumes qui disparaissent je pense
pas que ce soit le code netflix
cependant par contre qu'on a pu voir
avec le marché le marché du streaming
c'est qu'évidemment je parle ici des
offres vidéo surtout c'est que il faut
s'attendre et ça c'est aussi c'était à
prévoir tout le monde le savait que le
comportement des abonnés allait être
cycliques c'est-à-dire qu'ils allaient
diminuer leur loyauté envers un seul
service il se mettra essayé peut-être
même périodiquement certains services
ont savamment ce développement en
fonction des offres puis des séries qui
veulent voir effective bon le modèle
d'affaires vous l'avez dit ce qui est
particulier c'est que c'est les
abonnements point à la ligne c'est pas
les cotes d'écouté palais les
abonnements plus à d'abonnement bio de
l'argent puis plus à de l'argent plus on
fait faire des séries et c'est là partir
du moment où les abonnements baisse est
ce que vont songer à de la publicité bon
est-ce qu'ils vont songer à diversifier
leurs revenus via pas auront pas le
choix l'éclat en ce moment netflix un
problème majeur c'est que effectivement
premièrement il ya un problème de
rétention donc de ses abonnés là il ya
un problème aussi au niveau du fait que
on le dit là en fait la société déclare
que ya plus de 100 millions de ménages
qui utilisent son service sans le payer
une d'onkyo piratage énorme qui est fait
des services de netflix alors ça c'est
une première intervention à effectuer
reed hastings a déjà fait des annonces
dans ce sens là l'entreprise est au
courant de ça évidemment et tentent
notamment en déployant certains projets
pilotes en amérique latine je pense au
chili ou au pérou tente de récupérer en
fait une partie de ses de monétiser une
partie de ses prêts de mots de passe et
près de comptes netflix qu'on peut faire
à des amis ou à de la famille on va le
dire poliment donc c'est jean prat mais
il tente de monétiser ces choses là reed
hastings que longtemps rejeté le modèle
publicitaire en est venu forcément à
dire ben on aura probablement pas le
choix il va falloir qu'on développe une
offre hybride probablement comme
beaucoup de compétiteurs le fond on a
pensé par exemple à tou tv et tou tv
premium donc il ya des gens qui vont le
regarder avec la publicité et l'autre
gens qui sont prêts à payer pour madame
briceno on sait à qui parler désormais
quand on veut parler de ces choses-là on
va vous reparler parce que c'est un
nouveau monde puis comme vous comme l'a
si bien dit au début c'est tellement
monté vite et aux commandes il ya une
limite l'annex triple pas non plus
vendre des désabonnements des martiens
non plus alors merci de nous avoir parlé
je vous en prie bonne fin soirée noire